bonjour ariel berrino avec mercy est
d'être avec nous cet après midi sur
l'artère france comment expliquer que la
barre je cite critique des 300 malades
en soins intensifs soit franchie
cinquième vague trop fort pour mauvaise
gestion
eh bien c'est ce que la barre est
toujours une barre arbitraire donc je
pencherais plus pour une mauvaise
gestion sachant que il s'agit d'une
crise hospitalière et une crise
hospitalière ça serait que par une bonne
gestion
qu'est ce qui n'a pas été bien fait ou
correctement fait alors un atout à tous
il s'agit toutes ces mesures sont ne
sont que des illusions de contre de
l'épidémie mais pas du tout de même elle
ne contrôle rien du tout quand on sait
que les les virus circulent aussi bien
chez les personnes vaccinées que chez
les personnes non vaccinées pourquoi
ostracisés et discriminer les personnes
non vaccinées comme si c'était elle qui
s'est propagé la maladie moi je ne peux
pas m'empêcher entend spécialisé
épidémie de me souvenir ce qui se
passait à au 14e siècle pendant la peste
noire où il y avait de la médisance
contre les contre les juifs ont massacré
les juifs et on les brûlait pourquoi
parce qu on les accusait de
d'empoisonner les puits et puis il est
quand même cocasse que sept des dix ans
contre l'egypte au 14e siècle était venu
de la suisse à l'époque et puis au bout
de 4 5 ans la peste noire a bien fini
par disparaître et on en trouvera
toujours quelques-uns pour dire vous
voyez ça a servi de deux
de trouver les on a trouvé les
responsables et là qui semble un
responsable alors les non-vaccinés ça
oui là enfin disons les boucs émissaires
sont les non vaccinés je pense que les
responsables ce sont les pouvoirs
publics les pouvoirs publics qui font
des crises de nerfs qui font une course
internationale aux restrictions comme on
fait comme on faisait une course
internationale à l'armement mais ça veut
pas dire que les armes sont toujours
utiles et que ces restrictions sont
toujours utiles là l'an passé il n'y
avait pas de vaccin et on se retrouve
dans la même situation en europe que
l'année dernière ou presque comment
est-ce que ça s'explique
tout simplement parce qu'un vaccin n'est
pas une baguette magique que deuxième
nombre les vaccins
ne ne permettent pas de lutter contre la
contre la contamination s'agit de
défaire individuelle et donc on luttera
pas contre la contre cette maladie
uniquement avec les vaccins et puis
n'oublions pas que c'est comme quand
même les vaccins permettre de limiter
les formes graves de la maladie et donc
de faire en sorte que les hôpitaux ne
soit pas ou moins en tension
alors oui effectivement c'est celle et
c'est celle avantage principal a annoncé
des vaccins mais on peut ce 200 même se
demander pourquoi ne pas augmenter les
capacités hospitalières pourquoi ne pas
favoriser la médecine ambulatoire avec
des des traitements symptomatiques
simples comme par exemple
l'oxygénothérapie précoce à domicile
c'est quand même quelque chose de facile
à organiser la prescription
d'antibiotiques à visée respiratoire de
la classe des macrolides c'est quand
même quelque chose de facile à organiser
les anti inflammatoires comme quelque
chose de facile organisée si on prenait
on avait une
une attitude de deux
de promotion de la médecine ambulatoire
il y aurait moins de patients à
l'hôpital et donc moins de patients en
réanimation a laissé ces restrictions
qui sont donc mises en place aujourd'hui
en suisse qui touche essentiellement les
non-vaccinés comment réagit la
population helvétique à ces nouvelles
mesures est ce qu elle y voit un côté
liberticide
alors il ya une opposition très forte en
suisse mais comme vous le savez comme
vous le savez il ya eu le seul
référendum au monde qu'on sur l'utilité
d'un pass sanitaire a été organisée en
suisse à la fin du mois dernier et 60%
de la population a validé l'utilité du
paf il faut dire qu'on leur a promis que
le pont leur annoncer le pass comme
étant un passeport pour voyager donc
voter pour le passé puis comme ça vous
pourrez voyager en faisant en occultant
un peu le fait que quand on voyage on a
plutôt besoin de demander la permission
au pays où on va et pas obligatoirement
au pays d'où on vient justement la
suisse comme la france d'ailleurs placé
sur la liste rouge 10 elle les pistes se
refermer illustration avec les pays-bas
à nouveau confiné jusqu'au 14 janvier
qu'elle suit alors pour berne selon vous
écoutez les
les oppositions se radicalisent
évidemment elles sont elles sont très
importantes mais elles sont pas
majoritaires la majorité a besoin de
protection on ne peut que penser à au
discours de la servitude volontaire de
la police qui avait parfaitement analysé
les leviers de la delà de l'acceptation
de la paire de liberté quand on nous
promet en particulier la la protection
merci aérienne mais reste un acte avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes docteur en médecine
spécialiste en santé publique et docteur
en économie de la santé